hi there steve kaufman here again and
today i want to talk about
what i would call
false debates
in the realm of language learning or
language acquisition
what i mean by false debates i would say
that in my now 10 years or so that i've
been involved with the whole online
language learning community it seems to
me that there are two major sort of
points of contention
one is whether we should speak early
or whether we should speak
you know later in other words whether we
should focus on output or whether we
should focus on input so that's one
debate and the other debate is whether
we need grammar
or don't need grammar in order to learn
a language okay why i
consider these in a way false debates is
because
in both cases it's not a black and white
situation all right input versus output
of course at some point you have to
start outputting people learn languages
in order to output they want to speak
they want to communicate so
those people who focus on input
in most cases it's not because they
don't want to output it's because they
feel more comfortable
building up competence in the language
vocabulary comprehension before they
start
speaking and that is a personal decision
there could be some who simply want to
learn the language in order to read
books or under you know understand
movies so that they would be totally
passive but that's
not likely to be the case i think
there's very few people like it maybe
researchers or something like that most
people and and most people who do put a
lot of effort into input and comprehend
the language spoken and and when they
read they develop the ability to speak
however
people who want to speak early who have
an urge to speak who want to communicate
even poorly with whatever words they
have and they're struggling to
understand there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that and those people
necessarily have to invest time in input
activities even while they're speaking
they're listening they're gaining
something through input so
fundamentally there's no contradiction
with those two positions it's simply a
matter of what you prefer to do so to
that extent it's not a real debate just
do what you want to do some people say
yes but people wait too long and they
become afraid to speak i would think
that a person who's afraid to speak when
they have very little understanding of
the language
could in fact become less afraid if they
build up more confidence in their
ability in the language so it really
again comes down to personal preference
making sure you spend time with the
language now the other big debate debate
is the grammar versus
input now
i have said before and in my previous
video i said there are things that i
simply don't notice in
a new language and that it helps
sometimes to have this pointed out say
in a grammar explanation however
it's only after i've experienced this
several times that i even understand
this explanation and if i'm confronted
with the task of trying to remember when
i use this tense as opposed to that
tense
it's intimidating and if if the task of
learning a language
is presented to me as having to remember
this rule and the exceptions i find that
puts me off now there are people who
love that typically people who have a
lot of experience with languages and
they feel they can kind of shortcut and
get to the essence aha this language is
subject verb object and this other
language is the subject object verb or
something
i have personally never found that
useful when i went to learn japanese it
became immediately obvious to me that
the verb comes at the end so i didn't
need to see a theoretical explanation
that that is the word order but i can
see that it's possible some people find
that confusing so a quick reference to
an explanation like that can be helpful
and there are sometimes things that we
simply don't notice without an
explanation so again a mixture of some
degree of involvement with grammar to
the degree that we want to be involved
with grammar again a matter of personal
preference
and then
exposing yourself to as much of the com
content as possible finding things of
interest
beginning perhaps with simpler material
like our mini stories and ramping up to
where you can expose yourself to a lot
of audio and reading in the language
regularly referring back to
grammar issues when you're when you have
a problem and i find i do this i'll look
up the declension of a russian noun or
look up the conjugation of a of a
spanish verb when i'm interested and
then it sort of solves a problem that
i'm experiencing in the text
typically again if i'm trying to tag
this phrase for something now
bear in mind that i can't spend all of
my reading time tagging and doing all of
this sort of
careful
mining of the text i also want to get
that general exposure so you kind of
combine some degree of worrying about
the details in the nuts and bolts and
then a lot of just
getting the language in you and i have
referred to this 80 20.
you know the the the big picture should
be about 80
and the the picking at the nuts and
bolts 20 it's also sometimes referred to
as
you know
top to bottom which is the big picture
or bottom up where you're starting with
the bits and pieces and working your way
up to the the bigger picture but in in
any case here again it's not a either
this or either that i think it's a bit
of a mixture of both i think because the
grammar and you know nailing down the
basics which i don't think we can do
that this has been the dominant and
remains
to this day the dominant method of
language instruction it's good to point
out as krashen does repeatedly the
tremendous power of meaningful
compelling input and that in the end the
languages that we speak the best will be
those where we've had the greatest
amount of input and also where we have
used them but in order to be able to use
them a lot to have meaningful
conversations we need vocabulary we need
input so
to summarize then i think to some extent
those debates is more a question of
emphasis and that emphasis will depend
on our personal preference but one
should be open-minded to the fact that
different people react differently based
on these preferences
uh but
that uh
let's call it the revolutionary
value of krashen's emphasis on input has
been to move the sort of
dialogue in language instruction further
towards in favor of input and i think
that has been a very valuable
contribution one that
certainly reflects my views and
these were my views long before i
discovered stephen krashen these were my
views as a language learner so there you
have it a little bit about what i would
call the false debates in language
learning bye for now
and if you like my videos please
subscribe
[Music]
you